[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
bonjour à tous
je voudrais avant de commencer demander
à chacun de vous de regarder juste son
voisin côté et de lui dire merci d'être
la bonne personne au bon endroit au bon
moment jusqu'à votre voisin
il y a une chose n'oubliez pas
avant de quitter la salle n'oublie pas
de prendre le contact de celui qui est à
côté de vous
n'oubliez pas de tisser une relation
avec la personne qui est juste à côté de
vous
on vous dira que lors du 21e siècle
c'est l'homme
vous l'avez entendu
je suis heureux d'être ici et j'ai la
chance d'avoir dans cette salle
ma chérie Justine avec qui nous vivons
depuis 32 ans merci chérie d'être là
il a 12 ans quand tu me demandais
monsieur Baldi qui êtes-vous
je répondais que j'étais un ex mendiant
expert en échec
oui
ce que j'ai entrepris dans ma vie 14
fois et j'ai joué 14 fois
autre fois j'étais le visage réel de
l'échec ça y est ça juste de croiser
pour savoir ce que c'était que le chèque
mon père était enseignant il y avait
plusieurs enfants 17 enfants nous étions
je suis les jumeaux et prenant que ma
jumelle était toujours la primaire de la
classe son second que j'étais je battais
le record entre le dernier et
l'avant-dernier
puis ma plus grande chance
aujourd'hui ça a été
mon renvoi j'ai été renvoyé en classe de
6e
et c'est fini
quel visage pour un père enseignant
d'avoir son fils renvoyé en 6e
ensemble nous étions
tous à la maison mes frères à l'école
sauf moi je te souhaite apprendre le
carrelage donc j'ai commencé le petit
métier mais j'avais plus de chance que
mes frères pendant qu'ils étaient à
l'école que je revenais tôt tu n'étais
versé dans le livre j'ai commencé par
lire et apprendre
mondial de scooter
du Gabon a décidé que je lui montre
tu as raconté une question la tradition
qui existait nous avons fait les tours à
la ferme
et il m'a regardé il m'a dit jeune homme
regarde dans la boutique
choisis ce qui te plaît
cette question m'a étudi choisi ce que
ce qui me plaît
j'ai tourné dans cette boutique et
finalement qu'est-ce qui va se passer tu
vas aller choisir une boîte de les non
sucrés appeler communément bonnet rouge
j'arrive maintenant tu devais payer la
nôtre il me demande c'est tout ça je dis
oui c'est tout
et aussitôt
et avant qu'on ne sorte j'avais vidé la
boîte mais aussi tout j'ai commencé par
regretter mon choix j'ai pas jeté cette
boîte
je l'ai amené à la maison c'était aux
cheveux de mon lit chaque fois que je
devais m'amuser avec le vélo de mamie
qui me refusait son vélo j'allais
prendre ma boîte je disais j'aurais pu
être mon vélo
j'aurais pu être mon jouet
et puis quelque chose m'a dit mais si il
arrivait qu'on t'envoie quelque part
d'autre qu'est-ce que tu ferais c'est
ainsi que je vais prendre une feuille un
bic et commencer par établir tout ce que
je choisis dans ma vie
si quelque part m'envoyer faire un choix
je vais comprendre que le monde même
c'est un buffet vous laissez et Dieu
vous permet de choisir ce que vous
souhaitez
ça va être la première clé de ma vie
[ __ ] je vais commencer par
l'entreprendre je vais faire des petits
métiers j'en peux plus 14 fois je
voulais dire
mais je vais te dire
des échecs
qui ont fait de moi l'homme que je suis
aujourd'hui je dis pratiquement c'est
une chance mais je vous assure que c'est
pas évident
à la suite ça je vais être
employé dans une entreprise d'une grosse
entreprise de fabrique de savon
artisanal
je partirai de cette entreprise
comme
voyage représente en temps placé j'avais
commencé là en tant que planton de
planton je suis venu responsable de
production après VRP voyageur
représentant placier je t'ai chargé de
la provisionnement de la livraison des
relations intestins extraordinaire et un
beau matin
parfait
[Musique]
désolé
à mes côtés tout allait bien quand ça
nous étions dans une période de vache
maigre à cette période là on vendait la
production pour mettre la clientèle on
ne faisait pas de bénéfice
malheureusement pour nous le Nigeria
déversé sa matière première sur le
marché et malheureusement tout est parti
à l'eau
je me retrouvais me battre
c'est ainsi que je vais finir par avoir
de nouveau prêt
un embauche
dans une classe entreprise de
microfinance là encore je partirai de
là-bas comme directeur adjoint alors que
j'ai commencé là-bas comme chauffeur de
chauffage d'équipe de chef d'équipe je
suis devenu chargé de crédit [ __ ] chef
d'agence j'ai fini par directeur adjoint
point net renvoyer par la suite j'ai
fondé ma propre entreprise
je vais cette agence aussi va s'écrouler
je vais me retrouver trimballer de
commissariat en commissariat de
gendarmerie de tribunal en tribunal
jusqu'à ce que
en 2003
je vais me retrouver
ici à Abidjan
pendant que la crise battait son plein
je vais fonder une entreprise de prise
en charge des orphelins du fait du VIH
SIDA et passe 6 mois après j'obtiens un
financement il faut mondial de près de
20000 dollars fait de 20 millions de
francs je jette très bien c'est bon et
plus tard le gouvernement américain
l'ancien projet un projet appelé le MPI
new partner initiative nous allons
soumissionner plus de 1000 entreprises
africaines
d'un projet et le financement sera
hauteur d'un million de dollars
500 million de francs
désormais vos serviteur sera directeur
des programmes avec un salaire net
d'impôts de 700000 francs 1400 dollars
je serai pour la première fois aller
voir le concessionnaire tu m'as acheté
ma première voiture une Ford pour
l'option vous ouvrez la portière les
sachets 30 pour dire bonne arrivée
j'étais le boss ma vie était belle
mais tenez vous prêt les choses se
passent tellement bien qu'en 2000 8 on
nous dirait que la Côte d'Ivoire est
parti au rouge les bailleurs ont retiré
l'info je suis passé de 2 mois de
salaire payer à 13 mois au 13e mois plus
de revenu plus rien les enfants
connaissaient désormais un repas par
jour mes enfants avaient la difficulté
de continuer à l'école ils ont été tous
des scolarisés sauf ma future et petit à
petit la Villa devient difficile
pour finira c'est 8h sur serait obligé
d'aller voir son ex vigile pour lui
demander de l'emploi et c'est mon vigile
qui va m'employer employer en 2009 je
serai balayeur du marché gourou Adjamé
jusqu'en décembre 2009
j'étais malieur pour que c'était un
visage mais pour moi c'était une voiture
notable c'est alors que pendant que je
vivais ce moment-là on m'apprendre que
mon père est décédé qu'il faille faire
les obsèques difficilement je vais faire
les documents de mon père dans des
conditions que je dois vous compter
c'était dur je n'ai pas eu le transport
que le véhicule que l'avion emprunté
mon épouse de moi un véhicule qui était
dans une situation que je n'ose vous
décrire
je veux que tombera en panne
les femmes qui venaient du marché de 19h
elles ont plus peur j'ai commencé par
leur compter des histoires positives et
tout son regagne leur confiance et
certainement pas m'appeler reverra
pasteur je leur dis je peux pasteur
c'est la vie qui m'a tellement éprouvé
que je parle aussi bien
et nous arrivons donc à Abidjan le soir
même de notre arrivée quelqu'un
m'appelle pour me dire j'étais du voyage
je vous ai écouté parler je vous invite
à une conférence et cette personne
c'était mon voisin mon voisin de ce
voyage je suis allé de cassette
conférence
et c'est pas dans cette conférence que
Monsieur prendra la parole
pour expliquer ce que c'était que
l'activité qu'il faisait il va prendre
le temps d'expliquer ce que c'était que
la nouvelle tendance il va expliquer
que des années 80 on parlait de cette
tendance là de on parlait de
l'immobilier
à 90
vous vous souvenez d'abord 70 les
l'immobilier en 80 l'air donc de
l'informatique vu que tu vois le jour à
90 il va parler de l'air de la thévenus
mobile
envoie un portable c'était être
bosser d'une 2000 nous serons à l'air
du bien-être
à l'air d'une intelligence financière
qu'est-ce que ça vous a signifié
à la fin donc la conférence je vais
mâchoire pour voir bien comprendre de
quoi il s'agissait et c'est là où je
vais voyager je pourrai pas imaginer que
je faisais avec des choses aussi simple
qu'on pouvait mettre en pratique pour
mettre à mon projet sa vie
moi qui jadis était le dernier des ratés
je vais m'appliquer à ce que j'ai
entendu et 4 ans plus tard
tout va changer aujourd'hui je suis
l'auteur aujourd'hui ça flippe beaucoup
de choses
la première chose que je voudrais
partager avec vous
c'est tout ce qui m'a permis d'être à ce
niveau la première des choses se serait
quoi de savoir que peut-être que soit la
situation aujourd'hui la situation est
passagère
seul le changement est perpétuel les
choses changeront pour vous que vous
voyez ou pas l'autre chose c'est que
chacun ici quelque chose de même dans
lequel vous vous trouvez sachez qu'il va
falloir aller vers l'expertise en toute
chose et quand on parle de l'expertise
on a eu la chance
étudié rien ne s'invente quand je parle
ce que vous faites ou diminuer le
travail c'est un choix ça je fais 10000
heures quand je fais 7 ans
vous aurez à comprendre tout ce qui
trouve et vous allez atteindre cet homme
de sommet j'entrepris 14 fois je suis
parti de la base jusqu'au sommet parce
que je me mets entièrement je ne fais
jamais deux choses à la fois je vais
jusqu'au bout
n'oubliez pas de continuer pas lire de
continuer par les d'attendre chers amis
50 vous lisez quand vous emmenez vos
enfants à lire qui peut voyager avec le
monde qui peut tout changer tu aurais pu
croire
que moi renvoyer en 6e pour gérer un
projet de lieux said il va falloir que
je fasse qu'on appelle la capitalisation
des acquis il va falloir que je fasse
des études pour avoir mon DUT finalement
pour avoir un master en gestion
d'entreprise renvoyer en 6e aujourd'hui
je suis auteur mais tout est parti de la
lecture donc n'oubliez pas quel que soit
l'âge continue de lire continue
d'apprendre et ouvrir des sources
tout à l'heure j'ai dit de saluer
je pensais pas vous parler de mon voisin
de voiture de transport celui-là
celui qui m'a présenté cette entreprise
dans la conférence était aussi mon
voisin on nous dira que l'or du 21e
siècle c'est l'homme
ah oui il faut le savoir des gens qui
sont près de vous
bonheur
personne
personne vous ne peux pas savoir à quel
cm vous êtes de votre bonheur très
souvent nous prenons de véhicules nous
voyageons avec le monde sans nous rendre
compte qu'on s'est du passé avec deux
personnes qui donnent pas de doigts
auraient changer notre vie
je sais tu attends de chèque à chaque
fois que je passais je ne t'ai pas une
autre la beauté ce que je recevais
vedette franchement de quelque chose que
j'ai entendu de quelqu'un qui était pas
de moi autre chose que vous devez savoir
si vous êtes dans ce sale s'ils les
années précédentes n'ont pas été heureux
pour voir pour vous on dirait que l'être
humain
est la somme des 5 meilleurs amis qui
fréquente et sinon 2020 n'a pas été bien
pour vous 2021
changer le sexe de vos amis et si vous
êtes dans cette salle avec quelqu'un
c'est quelqu'un qui voit dans la même
direction que vous avez quelqu'un qui
peut vous accompagner ouais dans votre
vie donc ne l'oubliez pas non du 21e
siècle c'est qui c'est vous
et moi si j'ai été l'homme le plus
heureux je dirais de cette matinée c'est
parce que dans cette salle il y a une
personne exceptionnelle cette personne
qui
est venu apporter un plus à l'humanité
cette personne dont l'histoire n'a pas
été encore entendu cette histoire cette
personne qui a la plus belle histoire du
monde je voudrais que vous m'aidez
m'aider ou factionner cette personne
fortement sans plus tarder je voulais
dire cette personne c'est chacun dans
pour assis à votre place
merci à tous ceux qui sont présents
merci à tous tu as payé
permis à ce que cette activité se tienne
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]